summer is over and fall is here manscape
is here to make sure your pant pumpkins
don't get carved while you're getting
groomed that's right the new manscape
performance package 4.0 is here
shaving trimming upkeeping your balls is
hard work
manscape make it easy with their
performance package it includes
everything you need to stay fresh this
fall
lawnmower 4.0
weedwacker crop preserver and more oh
the lawnmower 4.0 is amazing
[Laughter]
it uses advanced skin safe technology
and cutting edge ceramic blade to reduce
those ball cuts yes and another thing i
love about their their crop preserver
nothing is like it's good on the balls
and the deodorant and listen it's just
the best ball cleaner in the history of
ball cleaning nothing like a good ball
deodorant
you know you're down there and people
smelling not clean enough it's just the
whole the whole experience is over uh
what are you talking about if you want
to get your hands on manscape
performance package 4.0 go to
manscape.com
now use code hotboxes for 20 off and
free shipping yeah and make your balls a
priority this fall choose manscape your
balls would thank you please
and mike sent you the cleanest balls in
the history of clean balls you are fair
but sometimes you'll be too
damn i'm nah i ain't going to say that
tonight hey hey they have big brothers
[ __ ] talking now we can fight i'm
gonna fight y'all nah i'm gonna fight i
ain't fighting you okay let's fight then
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you let's fight
[Music]
what's up everybody welcome to this
episode of hot boxing with mike tyson
i'm your co-host triple c aka henry
cejudo and i'm mike tyson tonight we
have the man of the man brother wale i
used to call him whale and [ __ ] damn
that's what i got
this [ __ ] you're the only [ __ ] that i
can't be like damn like you know but
that's not how you say it no that's
could get [ __ ] that's well if you say
well none of you other [ __ ] can get
away with it man
oh yeah thank you so much
tell me about you brother man um sister
was looking at one of your the biggest
hits man with chris brown play it please
you got a whole line of just a couple of
strands
a whole lime
yeah i did i did one dig right i sold
the most nfc that i got 800 000 for it
but it's in the states it's some [ __ ]
i've been signing it it pays back more
and more the more i get sold the more i
get money yeah those are you like your
digital trading cards right i've made
800 000 so far
nah
yeah i feel like still likes energy
feeling like you robbing the banks yes
but the people
i think i think the people at the end of
the other side of them that's getting
them those gonna be the ones that's
gonna be laughing last not that we ain't
gonna be laughing together but listen
they know what the [ __ ] they're doing if
a guy like me don't listen i don't know
what the [ __ ] i'm doing if i'm getting
eight hundred thousand imagine the
people who know what they're doing the
people who started this [ __ ] made this
[ __ ] you know what's crazy of this that
shit's gonna turn that's just gonna turn
into like 8 million
like even that one trading card because
think about it mike you know what i mean
like is it was it were there any
muhammad ali uh cards back in the day
like in boston yeah he had that but the
world was different then that's your
favorite box of all time right yeah
do you have a top do you have like a top
five
i'll be liking the [ __ ] that ain't
like everybody like i like i love the i
love the goats like but i'll be liking
the [ __ ] that just be with the
[ __ ] like you know who i used to be
entertained by you probably don't like
them prince not seen yeah yeah saying
yeah bro he used to just be like like
his little
listen and then we meet him in person
he's out of his mind for real oh still
his ego is so big but i just wrote like
i'm this is like probably eighth grade
seventh grade and i'm seeing this like
what is he uh like indian or something
yeah middle eastern
background dancers and he's he'd be like
he'd be dancing
like yo i love this [ __ ] bro but listen
like
that car accident thing that that that
kind of derailed this whole [ __ ] her
know what to cut thing was one of the
baddest ever do it
yeah yeah
sweet pea [ __ ]
sweet pea oh oh it's v8 right there so
wally so you can you keep up with boxing
a little bit a little bit you know what
i'm saying i'll put some [ __ ] on the uh
speed bag but let me get another go at
it though
i'm saying shout out to tiger boxing gym
over there swabbies when i gotta lose my
weight that's where i go listen you know
what the deal is entertaining that we
all starve entertainers and guys they
become sports figures they're big dope
dealers normally they used to live in
the same building sitting on the same
block and stuff and they just all make
it a different direction
yeah you know what's crazy that you
mentioned that mike you did manchester
check this out uh while he uh mike tyson
was born in the same hospital as michael
jordan
who who else was in mind that you're
telling me today bike league spike
league same month so this is in brooklyn
yes
i mean michael jordan mike tyson that's
two [ __ ] in the same biggie verse in
the same joint yeah yeah
no but there's more bro it's incredible
jackson same hospital we're born in the
same hospital y'all have y'all should
have statues in front of that
[ __ ] there they don't i don't
know
that that'd be a good idea for mike
tyson and michael jordan to have statues
in front of the hospital they were born
that should be a thing oh the most like
glitters [ __ ] from any like hot that
was born at a certain hospital
what does it mean brother well there's a
lot of different interpretations but
it's uh
my the king returns or the return of the
king or my king comes home like a lot of
little derivatives i said that would
explode for the past the return to the
king yeah you should have just been like
wild latin it's just a new new name like
just one word yeah
before you came up late well well tell
us a little bit about your story man
you're upgrading obviously your parents
are from uh nigeria right you see any
civil war yeah um
my parents from nigeria
they met at uh university district of
columbia i guess my mem like you know
nigerian parents don't really tell you
like it's not like i'm an american
household they're like this is how we
met and this is where your father took
me on the first date i don't know none
of that [ __ ] i just know udc
had my brother had me
we lived in dc for a little bit
then moved to uh blazenberg then we
moved to rockville
and then we moved to lagos i got
arrested in rockville oh yeah the boys
in brown
john didn't get montgomery county well
they don't know now but back then they
had brown jones i don't know if it's
still oh man
i'm in that [ __ ] what's the name that
lock up there oh [ __ ] don't worry i
forgot
about juvenile [ __ ] oh you did you in
that time
i was in this program
um
i know a lot about your story like you
know what i'm saying i met muhammad ali
been in the uh they they thought first
of all all right well as a kid
they put me in a special ed program
because i couldn't pay attention
i'm gonna especially that program
i want him in the hospital and in front
of the special ed program nah but um i
just had a hard time paying attention
they give you thor theme what's that
that [ __ ] that slow your ass down for
moving around ritalin they gave me
thought things they tried to get me
riddling well they didn't try they gave
that [ __ ] to me he said i was
like you know what
you know what i'm saying but and i was
in there first they called a special ed
when you're in elementary school how
many years were you in that the honest
truth i was not in regular school
after second grade after second grade
i was always in some type of program for
oh no he's just a little
and i mean i get it though i was
probably like a lot like i was very very
very new york this before you go to be
called a 600 school
well no school can take care of you all
the bad kids go to that one school yeah
and that's how i was i was like um
i couldn't pay attention and then that
that turned into just anger in my like
middle school years and then they put me
in another one that was more so like uh
that was more like a little
like i was more so like the structure of
it like i'm saying it was like two
security guards in every classroom it
was like six seven people
um it was one middle school and two high
schools did people make fun of you some
of this um i was good at sports man i
could dress i did my best with what i
had so i blended in nobody looked at me
like you know
i know probably look crazy like me
because when we had this little program
where if you if you if you do your time
enough in that joint they'll let you go
to your home school for like three or
four periods so when i got up i got up
and they started dropping me off trust
system right and when i got up when i
got up that joint they was like okay
well he's one of the best football
players we got even though i suff like
like you know
my confidence was like all over the
place like how you bag a girl
you just got off the short bus i found a
way though
i found the [ __ ] way i found a couple
ways
did you take the shark bus mike yeah did
take the short bus yeah yeah shout out
to the short bus again
i was fine
mike
get a long ass weapon on this short bus
damn
oh didn't the driver want to fight you
see now that's another level the driver
will fight you
you never went through that situation i
got suspended one time for my driver let
me off at the bus stop like it's a fight
at the public bus stop not the school
bus stop [ __ ] and brown's always
dragging that [ __ ] out ripping his
pockets out [ __ ] if you hit me what
mother he's a victim
he's getting robbed taking his watch his
wallet heavy that's another left that i
soup y'all going super saiyan with the
short bus
[ __ ]
yeah that's the allegory right that's
the allegory yeah that was tight
what was that what was the wallet that
uh that changed your career man what do
you think it was man what inspired you
man to be this why are you such a bad
[ __ ] he's trying to say well
why i'm such a bad [ __ ] i'm i'm i'm me
man
like i'm i'm me to the point like you
know everybody like i love my peers like
i don't got no issues with none of these
rap [ __ ] like you know what i'm saying
but i just do me i don't do i just do
what i want to do like i want the
[ __ ] wrestlemania and summerslam
because i like watching wrestling i like
the stories i like how that [ __ ] go also
you change the game and congratulations
on the wwe hall of fame do you thank you
brother okay cool i just want that
because wrestling twitter they're going
to know what did you get inducted mike
um a few years back
but then you went to the other company
though but they would pay more money i
know they can't understand [ __ ]
some [ __ ] is a draw
no listen
i was with you on that mic yeah but did
that storyline play out is it over or
you might pop up again i'm still friends
with the owner so he's still like oh no
yeah he likes my work pretty tony khan
is what they call them yeah
what about vince and them i mean i love
vince and number you know unless you
talk to them late not in a minute but
listen i love them and i respect them
but from a business perspective i have
to go the right direction they they
respect me for absolutely for sure sure
nah just because there's a big thing
going on in in that wrestling world
between those two companies you know
what i'm saying because i'm tapped in
every time they use me
they break the record every time yeah
every time i come on the show that's why
they use me a lot yeah not for sure they
i like what they're doing over there
you know but i i got i do work with wwe
like i do merge with them
and i respond
i respect both
in them realizing i want to be part of
the family now i just don't want to be
working for the weekend or working for
the week
yeah you know
i love them you did everything that
you've done but everything you've done
everything you've done in in in the
wrestling world has been cool
he used to sell out the garden like that
easy easy
nicholas cm punk is like that now i feel
like he's with that i mean as far as
popularity ain't popular popular [ __ ]
they just let you just manage somebody
just come down here talk your [ __ ] once
a week it's just you don't even gotta
get in there yeah yeah it's beautiful
it's like a soap opera for me yeah but
the [ __ ] actually got but like
on the athletic level on i've left like
you they have cars
like imagine running around athletes
though they're real athletes for real
for sure and i think people take that
[ __ ] like how much weight i was thinking
oh [ __ ] i wasn't talking about this one
i don't even know this one
i know
this wwe look how much weight i weighed
back then
you look like security uh love
you like about to put mine in the
chokehold at the club like
the shirt is like yo i'm gonna go get my
[ __ ] ass out you can't get this [ __ ]
well you know the impact that you've
been doing did you ever do wrestling
you've been on i've done i've done what
about like three of you been fighting
you
know
[ __ ]
but you and i'm like i'm like 200 pounds
of skinny fat
nah [ __ ] it's on stage but not for sure
i don't know i think i'm too shy for
that [ __ ] to be honest man
you're not shot [ __ ]
but you ain't your birthday december
21st what's that make you virgo virgo
man that means i overthink everything do
you think about vitamins and [ __ ]
uh yeah virgo was a health habit
[ __ ] i think they just pressed
about everything they just really you
know beyond this [ __ ] like
we're judging people
very very
but we're the most i think we don't
i think we're the most loyal we pick and
choose who we spend our time with while
oh [ __ ] remember holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
i have a guy i'm going there i'm a
wrestler here look at that oh yeah
[Laughter]
when he punched him for real didn't you
punch him for real at wrestlemania 17. i
forget i think he punched him for real
and he was like mad about it or
something backstage you got a woman man
a couple i don't want a couple you can't
say nobody's name how you love me no no
no no no no no no no
one of those girls
that was my reflex right i know you
can't do that can you say i know i got a
lot of [ __ ] i can't control myself
but sincerely my heart is yours
my heart is your body this can't stop
this [ __ ] i ain't hear you mike
what'd you say
no you kind of described it in the most
poetic way like i can't control myself
sometimes
and i don't even want to get nobody i
know it's like that that's why i said it
nah that's that's friday that's what
describing it you haven't talked with
your wife when they say baby i don't
know i don't have nothing close to that
why am i like this baby
why do you think i'm like this honey i'm
like what's wrong with me it could be
like everything no they tell me
nothing's wrong with you you're all
right so one time i'm doing this
we gotta we all go that route so one day
i'm talking
about my bachelor no
no
no
there's nothing wrong with you trust me
brother you're okay
you're okay everything is fine
everything's gone
everything's just fun but y'all play
ball i played um
i play football
and then capable [ __ ] i don't know yeah
yeah yeah were you any good bro cause
you both all right you're good yeah i
was good anybody in the rap industry
you'll beat them in ball one-on-one i
don't well i don't know i don't know how
to engage football one-on-one basketball
i'm like basketball i'm like i'm like a
c-plus b-minus in basketball
football i'm like a
good like b-plus but what's your
position in football well
i played running back in in high school
didn't i switch the receiver for like
the last four games
and then i got recruited as a receiver
before you got any clips on you on
youtube
they i got some of my mother house but
they just buried it on some dusty vhs
and every time i go there i'll be trying
to find it
but i gotta end up getting a scholarship
to uh robert morris university in
pennsylvania shout out to coach walton
in the whole moon township and then uh i
got in trouble
because i went to that i was i was in
that program so my my um my my grades
didn't like go over until like it was
like week five so that was like we're
gonna register at you
and in between my red shirt my red
shirting time in the in the spring i got
kicked out of school and then i
transferred to hbcu virginia state
and um
[ __ ] when did you know this [ __ ] was
going to pop this music [ __ ] yeah i
don't know man i was getting a different
energy at virginia state like i was
getting like just a different because i
wasn't really i was on the football team
but i wasn't concerned i was like man
and then we would do these battles by
the uh by foster i think it was across
from foster at the bookstore and like i
was always having my own my own flavor
like and you know there was feeling i i
kind of felt like i was just this [ __ ]
around the corner
around that time but it got real when i
transferred to bowie state
and uh you're a [ __ ] iridite
man all these [ __ ] schools you know
you're talking about he dropped out of
ninth grade but he's saying erudite and
i'm like what
you got the thesaurus on that i mean
you're an educator man oh nah i just
kept getting kicked out yeah but you
kept going [ __ ]
i want to play football defy but i'm
glad i went to one school and it's over
that's my whole uh no i was there i was
at bowie state you know man you tell me
you passed all those tests and [ __ ]
i did just good enough on the sats yeah
to to get to get a scholarship but um
again like the program i was in it
wouldn't allow my grades it took too
long because they never seen like no
school like that so it was just a weird
process when i'm in prison i write the
greatest you know be poetic letters and
[ __ ] and i still have them
no i don't even know how to start a
litter now
yeah you lost all your letters mike did
you did you draw a lot in prison i'm i'm
a horrible drawer yeah me too i can't
draw [ __ ] me too no no no when you say
writing are you talking about you like
as a poet or you to your family yeah the
letter to my family how long was you win
again three and a half
did you work out or you just chillin
yeah i got in shape i was i went near
like what
278 and left around 214. that's why he
was ready to eat [ __ ] family and kids
yeah that's why because
yeah you know that [ __ ]
returned to the king [ __ ] return of the
king
they came to the king
of the keg did you get in any did [ __ ]
ain't going to smoke when he was locked
up or you got into some [ __ ] [ __ ] want
to try your name everybody just loved me
but it's cool
everybody just gave me what i need they
didn't want me to go there they brought
me food from the child line so you don't
got to go up there that's what happens
the footage is out all right
people already had this they already had
the tape on him so when he got there
there's like oh no who's good mike now
listen all good i don't care how good
you fight them [ __ ] got cruising them
[ __ ] they're killing get up there for
murder they don't care about killing
nobody yeah
they don't care they're never coming
home they don't give a [ __ ] yeah that
people they shouldn't have put me in
prison for those guys man
you think it changed you huh you think
it changed you like as a fighter you
think that time changed you at all
i was never the same fight i just think
um i think that's just was the kind of
environment that i could thrive in this
this is where i've been on my life all
my life this has been most of my
surroundings and i started boxing and
now i'm back in it but once i i felt
very normal there
no more in there i felt very normal
there yeah
i knew what to do here
in prison yeah who's the first fighter
you got out i remember i think it was uh
the london [ __ ] oh the white guy peter
mcnairly man the crazy guy from both
them and then the then the winner what
was it uh bruno what's his name bruno
frank brown frank bruno i remember that
commercial on fox he was like frank
bruno something something something and
it was like showing i'm not gonna go
frank bruno some some some so i'm
knocking that guy i don't know why these
moments stick with me but i was like yo
because he was mad like like
but you beat the [ __ ] he's a big guy
beat the [ __ ] out of him
beat the [ __ ] out of him
yeah did people have some crazy [ __ ] in
prison did people make like crazy [ __ ]
like to like you know defend themselves
like you know what i mean um yeah
everybody had this stuff but um
listen man um
somebody went like listen
like if he'll have a problem with you
you're never gonna see her again
she's sending somebody ain't gonna never
see her again and now you got somebody
after your head you're never gonna see
them again yeah
and now somebody's gonna come stab you
or chop your head off
this is not depicted on orange is the
new black
black the black everything goes here
not everything goes on this [ __ ] hot
boxer nah i love i love it i love it
it's nothing but you've had a lot of
you've had a lot of interesting ones
you've had a lot of interesting you've
had a lot of interesting interviews
yeah yeah you'll get [ __ ] up i imagine
it's kind of like a hi you know it could
be
it may survive with the fittest
you know you have to be careful what you
say
be very careful what you say
did you did you still have the same um
like confidence when you came out like
as far as like being the greatest box in
the world yeah yeah i thought about it
every day i used to run him i used to
run in place in my room wow like an hour
and a half too late it's running place
running place rather place with my
headphones my radio did you ever in your
mind be like all right
i could beat all these [ __ ] except for
such and such and such things i might
have a problem with did you ever like in
your mind like i'm like this might be
this guy might give me some problems
well no i didn't look at it from that
perspective right
i don't know if you can allow me to say
i just look at the mess
they're a food that's how you're
supposed to look at them food yeah how
can how could they dare match me
yeah yeah you know you have to have that
kind of
perceptive perception of yourself right
it almost has to be thought status right
i agree
in any field any field but more so than
when it's with when it's like physical
like no in combat it's physical listen
if you lose a rap battle it feels just
as bad that somebody knocked you out no
it's probably a little worse if you
might not go out it's a different
embarrassment and also it's physical
pains
physical pain ain't nothing they can get
away from they can't get away from that
psychological pain
physical pain ain't [ __ ]
and [ __ ] this is the pain up here hey
man i've had like a
broken torn achilles i don't know man
that [ __ ] physical pain do be
hey physical pain is a [ __ ] you
know listen right um yeah but i think
mike's talking about more than mental
warfare yeah
when those guys had those spy the
what traitors and their torture in them
right
they tortured him so much where the pain
doesn't bother them anymore so then they
have to kill him
so don't tell me nothing about pain
when it stops hurting when people cut
you in pieces
broken leg broken achilles give me a
break
well one thing i definitely know about
is the mental part because [ __ ] that's
all the mentality it's entertainment
business you know your only purpose for
your body
who got empathy for the [ __ ] this
always on tv always on the radio always
and who got empathy for the [ __ ] that
are that are considered legends
they the the first thing [ __ ] assume
is oh your life is great you're a legend
you got money you got everybody
adulation they don't like who got who
has empathy for them well listen
why shouldn't anybody have empathy for
them i think everybody should have
empathy for everybody from this
issue but why because they succeeded not
because that but why doesn't when
something bad happens to somebody who's
highly touted or whatever the empathy is
is not it's it's low they'd be like oh
well this person died they shouldn't
have been doing drugs or this person uh
blah blah blah
they don't it's not as much as it would
be for like somebody else and i'm not
saying no nobody with no celebrities
nobody celebrities ain't above nobody
i'm just saying empathy is like
non-existent for
some people that really need it well
listen i don't know about that but i
know if these guys these celebrities the
way they now the kobe all these guys the
biggest star drake if they were in
biblical time they'd be in the bible
right you know how great they would be
in biblical times right
you know that's all it is the bible is
just a story about black people it's a
forever book
right the bible's a favorite book look
how many years right
look how fast everything is in and out
now
i think about that [ __ ] all the time
the bible is forever like it's people
every year
and the oldest person we know anybody
knows in physical form knows the bible
everything like this
yeah but check this out
are you a spiritual book are you
surprised
but no i haven't even checked out this
game and i'm a muslim right
this book representing god is if
whatever a thousand pages that's all god
give us the thousand pages that's all
this life is worth
from these books let me say jesus says
something in some interview i don't know
he said something about it being like
like a lot of i don't know maybe know i
mean i say because i don't know maybe
did he tell me this in private or was it
an interview
i don't know i'm high but
he the way he described that joint
uh it gave me a new perspective one of
y'all [ __ ] asked jay-z if maybe he
said it interviews i don't want to say
it because maybe i'm high and i just
told me that like at like some other
time and i'm just like saying some [ __ ]
but the the the what i'm thinking the
the bible being a forever book right
how to like well how many years was it
i'm not like a bit very in 2022. how did
that joint
that joint got remixes too like you know
this remixes to the bible but like how
does that transfer
to
200 years later and now
like you said like if things are
biblical like
you can't you can't you can't do not i
don't really even think that you can do
nothing now
that can last that long as the bible you
do you believe in jesus
i do
well listen why did they kill jesus
why why
why there's different there's different
because jesus believed the rich to give
to the poor
and they shouldn't be any poor
you know
he believed in that
jesus was a communist before communist
was invented
he wanted to help the people treated
treat them equally the poor
and if he came back he went the
same he wanted pretty much the same
treatment for the poor and no one would
kill him again because we love money
more than we love do you think that do
you think that we we treat the poor
worse now than than they did in biblical
times
no i'm not gonna say that
the only thing i think that um
we just have to know who we are as
people right and not lie to ourselves
and do some self-investigation right
you know these serious people who are
with people
man is um
you know i mean it'll be scientifically
proven that man is of
a compound of needs and necessities
that can never be fulfilled and with
when they are fulfilled you're left with
a
feeling of feeling this and abandonment
that's who we are we're some selfish you
feel you do you have an abandon do you
have abandonment abandonment like yeah
do you have i think i do too i do too
yeah i think like even like um i'm
chilling with a girl right or whatever
if i like her
i'm i might like go hard if i like her
like like you know i'm saying but if i
don't like her it's
like zero it's not it's like it's like
no i'm like i'm like a moving statue um
anything that i like like a lot i always
i'm always scared to lose it it could be
no remember like they say throw it away
if it's come back
yeah not [ __ ] that man i don't want you
to die
you might not come back i don't got the
boomerang you don't want a wife you want
a slave no i don't know
yes said you did no i don't want to you
said throw it throw her away
the third wave is meant to be you come
back but like
if it's a great if you're if you're
trying that test with a great woman how
do somebody else don't know she's great
what makes her great i'm just saying you
say uh you say if you want to basically
what makes the
a woman very christian
uh perception but your eyes make me feel
great because you know
what i think to make a woman great is
like personality
this which is very underrated you know
what i'm saying and just uh like
vibration the energy i respect that the
energy that she gave me respect that i
like because you know a lot of people
are like
um
i always got this motto
some girls
are in this around
for decoration some girls are around for
inspiration
you know what i'm saying some girls will
inspire you to be a better person some
girls are literally just like
it's not even real brick some girl some
girls are made out of this [ __ ] right
here emotionally inside and out some
girls are there for decoration
some of their inspiration
the girls out there for the inspiration
those are the ones and there's some
they're few and far between and yeah
then there's some to crush the world as
their feet too
they're not there for looking good or
being flawless they want to conquer the
world just like we do oh you talking do
you want to talk about declaration yeah
what about the declaration right yeah
that's not living that's 1950.
i'm not trying to like be little women
[Music]
you ever wonder what it's like to get a
million dollar payday now you can with
draftkings the official daily fantasy
party of the nfl get started today and
you'll be on your way to that million
dollars all you have to do is sign up
using code hotboxing then you pick up
your line and you say under salary cap
[ __ ] once that is done just see
how your team stacks up against the
competition in order to have that shot
of a million bucks download the
draftkings app now use code hotboxing
make your first deposit of at least five
bucks eligibility restrictions apply see
draftkings.com
for details
[Music]
yeah cause you obviously you've
experienced a lot of things mike is is
that what made you compassionate michael
oh no that's all i have is compassion
because if no one gave me compassion
i'll be nothing yeah because the world
could give me compassion
now you got one of the biggest hearts
though you'd be like hugging pigeons and
[ __ ] like that that's a different level
of another passion that's something i've
been doing on my i don't even know why i
love them that's been doing it so long
and that's not even a glamour it's not a
glamour pet like it's not a [ __ ]
alligator or whatever like a chihuahua
whatever [ __ ] pigeons
but also can fight like [ __ ] though no
but listen this is the very important
position pitching was the first um
mailman
they carried mail cleaning with the
first guy that they were using during
the crusades before christ
jesus had pigeons
they all had pigeons back then yeah that
was a sign back in the day because
pigeons don't do that no more they what
are the pigeons fall off because they
don't do that normally you may fall off
did they fall off they're not as hot as
they was yes they are they used to be
hot
they were saying
excuse me put up the most expensive
pigeon in the world please
put us on because i can't wait for jay-z
to watch it and be like i'm buying
pitches now and tell me how much they
call i can't wait drake going had a the
pigeon
where is it from belgium
drake gonna go to belgium buy that joint
we make it hey listen
hey
hey listen can i tell you something
about drizzy man that guy won't send
that celebrity for 100 million what the
[ __ ] do that do is [ __ ] diamonds you
can't yeah yeah that's what it does it
got to that's what it does why no why is
it so much mike no i could dig right
because
who's his mother and father who's his
grandparents who's his grandparents the
pigeons not the owners bloodline okay
just like your human race
what is it about that bloodline though
mike what is it about that bloodline now
the blood is made of champions infinity
stones no champions and wakanda
to win born to win refuse to lose
what does it mean
what is the prison going on what is a
pigeon gonna win though what can a
pigeon win they know that they know
they're the most
flying things
high building and no they know they're
racing getting a cracker award yeah what
a lot to them
flying down from
no one wherever to get like a sunflower
seed award they're running to get back
to love yeah i'm talking about pigeons
man come on man who do it like mike
tyson man did you ever buy expensive
pitches my school are you more expensive
i never i have some home opinions you
bought expensive you bought expensive
pigeons yeah
you bought them yeah
i would have
i would have got like a cage and just
just just went outside with like some
sunflower seeds listen and then got them
for you mike
you still want pigeons i'll do that [ __ ]
now
i'll i will go on hollywood boulevard
and be like
and i'll put in mike tyson on the roof
with his pigeons see what you see i
didn't know and jimmy kimball's show a
pigeon is a bird that is something
remember that uh i don't want no pigeons
opinion is so loyal you wouldn't believe
it opinion died before
him had died
some and some in world war ii they've
been shot they still they walked home
they were shot down they walked home
pigeons
imagine all those animals that could eat
them and he still got home i just hired
security is that one for me in the birds
i'm in front of
you
oh man that's the old one man
i don't even live there no more
is that like is that in arizona yeah you
can't even see my bro how about in
manhattan new york this wwe time he just
got off the stage with that with chris
jericho on this one what animals you own
now you do you want any animals pets i
have a dog what's his name again what
kind of dog is that
lava doodle
and i have um that's a small joint right
no this big we're trying to buy the
small one but they gave us the big one
you remember arnold schwarzenegger's uh
a pony we went to his house yeah i'm
just talking about it
right there
who's that what's that man that [ __ ]
was my favorite boxer all right that was
the man man
god
you can't even see me with my bird
that's my [ __ ] what makes a pigeon
better than the parrot i'm not saying
who's [ __ ] listen check this out you do
have an affinity for pigeons yeah i'm
not saying who's better than who is no
opinion of course more than let's look
at the most expensive um parrot how much
that cost that might cause more than a
day that's what i'm saying this [ __ ]
might be on some other level and he'd be
trying to underplay it i think that's
his gimmick though how to [ __ ] he knew
that [ __ ] was worth millions before we
even did it and it blew everybody's mind
but we got to be act regular because we
don't want to be like yo this [ __ ] is
of savant
how many aliens
so the most expensive parrot is forty
thousand dollars what's the most
expensive bird in the world
if this if it comes back as this vision
i'm leaving i just want to say hey let
me say goodbye now not this big thing no
no no no if it comes back it's this same
pigeon i have some horses
they got some races today
is it going to be this picture
[Laughter]
am i being like no
i don't know bro let's just kind of
[Laughter]
on i don't want to ask anymore i'll do
my own research can you go back to that
next one what fifteen thousand
[ __ ] got a uh number one fifteen
thousand
well that's forty that's the closest one
forty forty
look at that [ __ ] look like [ __ ] right
now there's some [ __ ] gotta get that
jumper 40 just to boil it and see if it
go good with stuffing
that million that milly milly rock
that milly rock differently for the bird
man
you can never let it as the prisoner for
life
yeah man you let it out that's the most
expensive
that's the that's the most expensive
jail in america or whatever whatever
listen you're right
you're right 15 milli for it and he
can't see him
he can't get calm
[ __ ] she sits down she moves uh me and
my tight man and he gets on back
[ __ ] by mike tyson ready go then he
gets on top of him busting her guts out
that's what he said i thought he was
well him he was telling the truth but i
agree because he's mike tyson and i
don't listen i just love my limbs
everything i talk about i'm an expert
then so let's talk about something
you're not an expert in women
[ __ ] [ __ ] how many kids you got you
expert or something but i'm not an
expert in having a cool understanding
with them let's talk about the
uncomfortable [ __ ] so when it can go
viral there's nothing uncomfortable no
no no i know i'm on this program i watch
i watch i watch the interviews man
nothing uncomfortable i just want to
tell you i love what you've done with
your career in your life because you you
you've become like a media darling i
ain't [ __ ] no no let me get this one off
cause i've been i was practicing in the
car not really but kind of in my head
you the baddest man on the plane
oh my god mike tyson he was like the
boogeyman till now it's like oh my god
mike tyson's one of the greatest media
people in the world and you would jump
in and do do the trailer [ __ ] show you
still got hands
move around
like and it's it's just inspiring
because it's like
i don't know if
like i i i could say you're not a rapper
but i consider you hip-hop culture i
think everybody do i don't
as a when i first jumped into this when
i was like 19 i was like how does [ __ ]
going to be in 30 years like how hip i
gonna be in 40 years 20 years and i just
think that [ __ ] like you joe
um
nori fat joe
um are just showing us how
our culture is going to age gracefully
no no
i disagree in that moment
that's showing you
how to survive
i don't you're not surviving though bro
you're doing you're doing you're doing
things that you didn't say thriving but
surviving just being existence i like to
exist to be able to do things well
they're probably the same thing we use
in different words do you feel like
because you say survivor and that means
bottom like like scraping to just be
afloat you're not afloat [ __ ] listen
i'm gonna be afloat with a 10 billion
i'm going to be a flo that's not a fl
that's that's that's prospering i feel
like what i'm gonna be struggling man i
have 10 billion [ __ ] that's a float
right when you don't have it you're
going up right that's a float trying to
get there no back yeah i'm one of those
guys
you're doing great though how many
people i can help with a billion dollars
you don't know well you're doing great
keep like keep doing
the point i'm making everybody because
we have all right like he do a lot of
what he's doing with what he's doing and
it's showing you know that like there's
a there's another level right mike's a
giver dude i remember i was with you in
new york mike and i'll never forget it
man because we went out to the street
and then there was a bum that came up to
us and asked uh
you know that he was kind of asking for
money and you pulled a wad of hundreds
and you gave the you gave that bum a
hundred bucks but he had no idea who you
were
and everywhere he like look he's like
are you serious like you started
reacting
but then you kind of told them you gave
them 100 billion you said hey man i get
out of here man the dude's like yeah i'm
gonna go buy my clothes like no just get
out of here like don't come back
do you do you remember that mike
but i don't know
but i know what happened because that's
just what i do i keep a
pocket full of money for the homeless
every day yeah but a hundred dollars you
know what i'm saying like it was it was
different because it was it was you know
it was super it was generosity that the
dude has never in his lifetime been
given a hundred dollars so this wasn't a
homeless person so i just want to do my
disclaimer but i relate because i want i
was buy cookies
you know the weeds on the melrose on my
cookies and
the fruit man is right there and i
bought like a little like ten dollar
fruit bowl and i just gave him a hundred
dollars right
didn't make a big deal i just gave it to
him shook his hand and moved
i went to the studio for like two three
hours
came back he was still there
i was like yo what's up man um
trying to get another joint i was like
oh you remember i came by earlier my
money was out for my next joint
and he was just like i've never seen
before in my life
same [ __ ] i just gave up like a 90
dollar tip to me well that's i don't do
it because i like these people nah i
just felt like no i've had good commerce
i've had good karma i lost my wallet in
the strip club [ __ ] enough i found it
so i think that was because of the tip
no no i need to do it because that's the
tax i pay for living on this planet
other stuff is probably just extort
legal extortion but i know
taking care of the people is really
paying the real taxes while you're alive
i learned that from muhammad ali
are they paying the people the poor is
paying taxes for your life on earth
taxes are you know what i mean that's uh
that's legal extortion some people think
that the key
expound on like because i don't think
nick i don't think the [ __ ] know what
like how they be doing [ __ ] with taxes
well listen i don't want to talk about
taxes they might get mad if i tell you
the history attack
well i might tell you that oh
man they've been on uncle sam man ain't
no uncle
uncle sam is the most powerful guy in
the world we got to stay on his side
yeah
you just brought up ali man
did you have a friendship with ali or
was it a mentorship like how was it with
muhammad ali your relationship
worshipping [ __ ] how he just worshipped
him he knew he was great
is he the number one boxer of all time
in my life i believe so what about uh
shane roberts he's great too
ray robinson
that was muhammad's hero i know so but
who's the master or the teacher the
teacher or the learner listen i'm just
giving my opinion ali was um under 60.
he was 160 he was 160 ali was 220 218
and ali was faster than him so you tell
me who's better when you when you when
you was coming up right
so muhammad ali got a whole nother style
to you yeah but that's who you worship
that's who you you know you know you got
you got a custom motto that's the name
right that's how you say that so
you you you training and you know
at some point you had to know like damn
like i'm really good at this [ __ ]
did you in your mind was like i'm doing
the same thing ali was doing
but i'm a completely different
absolutely with the same
um desire for the win yeah the same as
ali had ali was a different kind of
fighter but it's so crazy to me that at
least his inspiration but it's like
he's doing a whole nother style where
it's like you can only enjoy muhammad
all these fights
i leave ruined so many heavyweights
trying to copy him they they say this is
impossible why why am i gonna do this
you know so i'm not gonna be i'll listen
at least six three and a half i'm five
ten and a half i'm not gonna be able to
fight these monsters these tall guys i
gotta eat for right when did you know
that when did you know that she was
gonna be we was gonna be beating this
[ __ ] out of grown man around 14.
no professionally 14.
so you started training that i thought
10 13 14. okay if you said like 17 i'm
like damn he was practicing on the
street with [ __ ] yeah
yeah
no no yeah and 12
13 i was knocking cats out i looked like
this at 12. no you give me the energy of
the [ __ ] that i was in the program
with they were just
fighting they just could fight
not not much on conversation
bad fight though they will fight that's
all we did all day was fight for it all
day in bounds do you remember how you
felt your very very very first fight the
very first professional a professional
yeah i knew this guy wasn't gonna last
long did you did everybody know he
looked he was a pumpy fat guy
so who's the first one that you was like
all right i'm going to fight i got i got
i got to fight you strategy not just
not just beat them right probably when i
went 10 rounds with james
james tillis because cowboy told her
because he was more experienced i mean i
went to distance with him
but after that i went to this like 10
rounds again with mitch green but then i
knocked everybody out after 10 knockouts
after that you've realized like
i know [ __ ] be on here kissing his ass
and everything all the time i'm trying
but but i'd be very
[ __ ] tired no i don't i mean nah
cause i [ __ ] i think he knows but a
conversation
no do you realize like
i don't know man maybe i just can't draw
it right now maybe somebody's getting it
bro
i got to come with something
he has one of the
most like
force gump careers because think about
everything he's done right
four's coming in he's just been
everywhere then [ __ ] been on
wwe aw
got trained by one of the greatest you
know what i'm saying
uh
pop
right there oh dude
speaking about that it's hot right it's
just if like everything that's combined
of mike tyson is so crazy [ __ ] uh
what's that movie called uh
hangover right
listen what fight was that
i mean i was my tilden that was my
sheldon
when he was out i think third or fourth
third third one that was when i was on
fox i think listen but all i've been all
those guys and all those things right
and that could be that could be
titled the label there's greatness right
what kind of person is in my mind
only oh no yeah
the guy that has all these assassins
what kind of person you think he should
be you know he she would be doing all
that the person who established all the
things the words that i did yeah how
should he conduct himself
by his establishment rhetorical yes it
is
okay but by by looking at his
credentials
what would you think which way how would
you think he would carry himself from
his credentials
so it's not rhetorical
what i'm saying is you showed [ __ ]
bro you came home
you was talking so like in another
you was just levitating like he was just
if twitter was out right and you joined
from that
you you stopped boxing you was in like
iconic movies doing uh uh wrestling the
aew got your weed strand got a podcast
going do the chilling [ __ ] about that
and you did it and you you know [ __ ]
was against the odds you know we was on
the short bus like we said yeah he's on
that [ __ ] small joe and look
what you've been doing
tyson's ranch i'm not even know a lot of
them
probably thought that no he ain't going
to be
after this
no [ __ ] you came back and you still
doing it i don't know that's this is who
i am i had a tea i just want to be up
more than anybody wants me to be down
that's just what it is
well you great [ __ ]
i'm not i'm not here
[ __ ] kiss your ass about the boxing
[ __ ] whatever that everybody know he you
one of the greatest boxers i'm talking
about how you did this this this
this whatever the like you just do
what i'm saying i met a lot of great men
right i love met a lot of great men most
of the great men i met was met wasn't
good men
so i work hard on being a good man
more than anything [ __ ] all those
accomplishments all right everybody got
feelings scumbag you got the car
everybody got flawed like you said
everybody got floors though
sometimes he's just a great man then
come on go ahead come on
you're driving the car you know what i
like you you know what i like about you
i got a vibe like if you go too crazy
like whoa we back here yeah
no you know what it is but we vibing but
then we gotta remember we're doing this
[ __ ] too yeah and he'd be like skirt
he's like yo get this [ __ ] off
the set i don't like him he's really hot
he's high with mike if one [ __ ] be the
straight man and it might be higher than
nice
[ __ ]
figure it out
because that [ __ ] left we gonna be
calling [ __ ] on yo remember when these
guys
i was a recruit before i got here mike
you know what i'm saying
but i will say this mike mike something
about you mike is your fair bro and
that's what i love about you mike that
you're a fair human you know what i'm
saying like you know if you [ __ ] up
like obviously you paid the price like
you know what i'm saying
and that's what that's what i love about
you mike listen man you you are fair but
sometimes you'll be too
damn i'm no i ain't gonna say that to
myself
that's gonna be good for a little bit
though when i say [ __ ] you to mike tyson
i would never
i would run so fast i will run i will
run to lax
security well i i do this from practice
while late because i know if you can
make me angry you own me
yeah no no i heard you say that
yeah i disagree a little bit because i
think if they could make you angry if
you don't own me like [ __ ] you might be
owning some other [ __ ] you might be
owning a spot and see the sienna
whatever that [ __ ] called
my man i'm about exactly i don't get
he's on bro short
i was not the [ __ ] that was fighting
everybody don't get twisted i was a
[ __ ] that was just like
making fun of the teachers not listening
just
take medicine to this day i will not
answer that question right now big
medicine to this day i don't want to
answer that question right now yeah yeah
i got anxiety that i definitely got
anxiety and um i'm not um i'm not good
in social settings
i two therapists said i got this thing
called um
avoidant personality disorder
and um that's what genius fritz uh
what's that [ __ ] nietzsche had that
[ __ ] too hey bro can we go to the studio
this week like nick snicker is my next
producer [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
what's up nah nah like we gotta go to
the studio you be saying some [ __ ] you
be saying some [ __ ] i need to write down
when the beat is playing you said avoid
the personality what's you brother michi
yeah frederick lee when the baddest
philosopher yeah well
you know cause veterinary didn't need
the first three games late
no don't let them talk about the dropped
out [ __ ] no more the [ __ ] is
a [ __ ] professor right now [ __ ] like
will you go and go to morehouse and
teach a class [ __ ] you be knowing too
much [ __ ] how do you know about
nietzsche when you read about nietzsche
in prison
touche
president you got a lot of time you can
probably teach anything after
wagner you know
what i want to hear about that i want to
hear about the avoiding personality when
you're watching the first name nichi
uh avoided mike nietzsche no avoiding
personality because i want to know
nietzsche believed god was dead right he
believed god was dead and the older man
or the underman
was not the god he the strong man wasn't
the man that fight back or destroyed the
straw man was the one that could endure
the most right that was the superman
that was the open man that's the one
that can dish out the most the one that
could absorb absorb the most like
rope-a-dope kind of
didn't he take all that he took all that
because he couldn't endure him but i
lead took some punches but he avoided a
lot of punches too this is just full
flash everything in your face cardio too
though endure the endure like moving
around and you know i only had 100 200
amateur fights experienced fighters come
on
go ahead i know you want one
do it what are you talking about no
that's my man does he make sure me and
he makes sure me and mike don't go be
gonna be talking about some other [ __ ]
yeah ask liam no no
what i want to know bro is what snacks
do what's that's on the horizon
i'm vibing with you like that so i'll be
forgetting that i i literally forgot i
make music for like the last 30 minutes
but who do you want to work with next
you ever work with drake i got love for
drake man how about lil wayne i work
with wayne
you know what i'm saying but you know
drake the hottest [ __ ] in the game
because drake is probably the biggest
artist on the planet you know and we
came in at the same exact time you know
what's that
so you always have to be someone like
that huh always have to be the show
drake i like i i got this thing i always
say like drake is like uh
the per like everything he do is like
damn like if you could if you could do a
creator
rapper like on the video game does drake
he can say he can rap he know how to get
with the [ __ ] you know how to get in
the streets like drake knows what the
[ __ ] he's doing but that's a busy
[ __ ] for sure i don't know if
he's gonna do no we got one together we
got a platinum record together but so
what's up man you know you're going to
take oh you can take you're going to
take over the game dude that's what i
want to know hey listen am i going to
take over
what's up [ __ ]
i don't i hope so
it's your african brother over here man
oh what's up boy listen
damn that was job racist how i put my
glasses up
nah my bad fool i just did it because i
was like let me i i why would why would
they come
but um that's my [ __ ] right there man
he's been doing a lot of things for
africa as a whole
that's why he's here brother yeah
he was like man i got this african [ __ ]
wally i don't know nothing about him can
you come here real quick
give me something
make this [ __ ] man make this [ __ ] shut
the [ __ ] up
you like that but damn man
no
no i mean i'm just really really really
uh
i ain't gonna hold you i was a little
like
um
nervous maybe a little bit
bro
i was born 84 like you or
come on man imagine being 11 12 years
old when you
[ __ ] punch out [ __ ] you know i mean
you made me cry
and punch out you made me cry
and mike tyson punch out bro that was
what do you mean everybody zero zero
seven three seven three five nine six
three i got any water got any water zero
zero seven all you uh somebody zero zero
seven
three seven three when that's cool five
nine six three matter of fact that need
to be his next merch just with that
number right there watch how fast it
sell out
just give me a rolly when it go crazy
this is what i wanted to tell you zero
zero seven three seven three five nine
six three y'all hurry up mike that's a
bunch of straight stuff yeah i told you
the nft [ __ ] i can't believe i've got
that much money i don't even know how i
got that money i didn't do [ __ ] nah
that's not true mike that's all that
hard work that you've done that's no way
listen
said it again i'm a little you know i
mean i worked for everything i got
but i don't got everything i worked for
that's how you feel
how [ __ ] yeah yeah
but
a lot of [ __ ] that came with you that
was running the race with you that were
in that same little of the same elk they
not doing like you mike listen they're
not they're not they're not doing like
you listen they're not miserable like me
too i'm a monster i have to succeed
how are you miserable because my mind
don't stop i constantly think of because
it's defeating that's cause that's what
that's what happens with geniuses the
[ __ ] in the back of the shore bus
that's what happens when we get older we
become geniuses but we become tormented
geniuses and nobody has no [ __ ]
empathy for us that's what happens mike
listen right
would you be like [ __ ] it [ __ ] all this
[ __ ] i'll be homeless on the street if
my mind will slow down
no no no no
i've been homeless because of this show
no now though now though
your mind don't stop because you're a
media person you're if you're you're
you're still boxing actively you're
doing you're doing movies your mind
ain't going to stop you oh no listen my
listen let me tell you something i'm
married right for like 13 years yup
right
and um
that's not right i am
right it's over me man drink sandwich
my wife is not my fan she's not my fan
so she's gonna call my [ __ ]
all right
and that's a life in itself right so
life it's just a life in itself
so i'm at home i'm just
a father at home a husband at home i
know i'm no superstar at home but then
when you go out to work
yeah you you hit him again yeah but she
spies with me too
she makes that makes me like maybe you
just want to make her you just want to
make your family proud at this point
well listen i do but you know um
my wife is my wife is not naive or
anything
yeah you know just that we have an
understanding and we love each other we
have a wife out she's naive
no you don't know when that night you
know get back not the joke i was trying
listen you're a king
and the lion's a king a lion needs his
woman to be visited
that's what the court you're talking
about what
what the
what are we just talking about oh he hot
too damn um nah something about lions
and kings and then
women well yeah women you know being
married murderers marriages that
marriage is a scary thing because
you know what it was when i was young
when i was just coming up there were men
women that were married
like older women i was married i was
trying to get at me so what that teach
me about marriage as a young i'm like oh
[ __ ] this is that [ __ ] that y'all do for
show
but y'all gonna do what y'all wanna do
why like brad
my first three tours those married women
that was
you know just
promiscuous a big game right
no one has to tell you if it's wrong or
right your conscience tells you it's
wrong or right even though you did it
and you felt good you know if it was
wrong or right i'm not saying it was
wrong i'm not saying with rasa you know
if it's wrong or right
yeah do we
no we know we know who we are we know
our consciousness
what advice you got for wale uh like it
was just um he's who he is i have
nothing to say he's doing everything
right i'm just i'm very grateful that he
came on the show and um he has a lot to
give to the world
yeah
that's my belief only and people could
think of this yeah yeah he asked me the
same question no that's good no no i
want you to close it out for us dude no
i want to give him i want i want you to
ask me the same question
to about all right yeah what do you what
advice would you give me the greatest no
no no no no no no this ain't no action
no this ain't no i
i just think that like i said before
like
you know in hollywood they call it
rebranding or whatever the [ __ ] i don't
i don't call it that i just call it like
you evolved he was the baddest man on
the planet to
one like the villain to
uh
you know stepped away from a little bit
and then
like became an icon to kids now the the
the people that grew up in my area the
people that grew up in your era and the
people older you've managed to do that
and that's that's not a that's not easy
bro yeah that looks good but chip came
on this right
i have a guy known ever since i was like
17 years old he's um
he's pretty successful too we were kids
because he's pretty successful too so
now he made a mistake um with some women
he's me too but i can't talk to him he's
my childhood friend i can't talk to him
because he has some personal problems
i'm a bad guy if i told him even though
i didn't do nothing if i talked to him
i'm a bad guy now i can't talk to him if
i say something i hang out go to dinner
with him i'm me too i don't understand
that well that's what my i think that i
think
is that is that that's not illegal like
you're saying
you're saying that you're not you can
you can talk to whoever you want to
you can talk to everyone but you also
you can also share your evolution with
these [ __ ] too though no but listen
this is my friend that ain't no no i
know but you can still but you
you've been in that space you've been in
that space where you know the world
ought to back you you gotta have to
offer with [ __ ] like that too though
right no i don't know i don't understand
that i don't understand how everybody's
scared to go near somebody because they
they're called dirty or something when
are we going to be men we don't even
follow the constitution we're scared
somebody's going to
not work with us no more because we're
talking to somebody they don't like how
does that world exist well i think
that's what i mean i think cancer is
common can we do cancer culture i know
yeah thumbs up a thumbs down cool cancer
culture is it is it's a thing it's it's
it's only real to some people it's not
real yeah but what is it what does
castle culture even mean though
what does that mean i mean it means like
it's over with it's over with it for you
you know what i'm saying
we saw
everybody say
then i saw off stadium full of
[ __ ] watch them levitate out of
the arena
you know what i'm saying it's just the
same [ __ ] man
what is like i'm saying like kanye
yeah
yeah yeah i never knew that yeah did you
know that much
hey let's check that [ __ ] out
levitating [ __ ]
black laxating no levitating out of the
band's arena
i can't think no the [ __ ] the [ __ ]
really like like everybody was trying to
fake cancel him what i'm saying is
you stand by who you stand by you know
but my thing is just be ready to explain
it when it's time to when it's go time
that's it
that's it because they're going they're
going to try to associate that's that's
how they like to cook it up stand by how
you want to stand by hey khan you still
buy somebody everybody
you know
were you just like
but just be ready for the be ready we'll
come with you that's all it is
this is what this is your friends [ __ ]
friends you gotta get on the damn show
that [ __ ] was young
oh yeah
i know he was in the mix bro i ain't
know he was a mix like that he's
crowned talking about crown royal
brother
you remember when i came to your crib
and i played you pyt he was like this is
going to be your head baby
i played there that people i teach on a
con like it's gonna be a hit
and i'm a [ __ ] platinum
that [ __ ] knows [ __ ] now
you know [ __ ] he's um he's a builder
he's the super builder
i know
he make mega mega trying to tap in with
him but he's just a busy guy i don't
know i came to pick his brain i don't
like anything huh maybe acon don't like
me mike tyson only you don't like you
because he's like nah what if akon don't
like me mike tyson he loves you he loves
everybody
that's my man for years not as long as
you though
shout out to boo too that's my [ __ ] too
what's that kanye
that's a kanye level
that's how he ain't levitating anything
oh you thought you thought i said he was
like really levitating yeah
this [ __ ] ain't david blaine
[ __ ] like he's he makes he raps
he don't do magic now yeah of course he
y'all nah
i mean i could i mean yeah you ain't
really think i thought he lives
levitated it's not just me did you like
his music that much i thought that dude
was walking on water he thought he was
[ __ ] that me and mike could be high you
gotta be like you know those were
strings right like
i thought we all knew that but it's cool
the [ __ ] levitated still you do the
toad brother
what yeah yeah you're gonna you're gonna
need the toad i think
what's going on right now somebody's
told this this is this is what gave mike
a whole new perspective dude listen i
got a minute
that's why they told us right there yeah
look at this see that take the national
football team
the indians um
oh gosh shamans
i'm making the show
i'm going all over the world trying the
indigenous yeah oh you [ __ ] with the
shamans have you ever done shrooms
wasn't that streamed out yesterday
micro or macro no i do the candy bars
yeah because it tastes so [ __ ] bad
the ones from the dirt you know
i've had i've had molly that tastes
worse so [ __ ]
what was that molly i've had no i've had
no i don't currently [ __ ] like don't
try to use this that's all good no i
know i know
well that's what i'm in right now you
see the shamans and [ __ ] putting people
to sleep and letting them see god so
isn't there like that's
shaman is like shrooms and [ __ ] right or
like something else oh psychedelic you
got so much stuff you got the scorpion
you got the toe you got the white what
the [ __ ] is the toad bruh that's what it
is right there no but what is what is it
though like what is it that's the [ __ ]
it really gets you high oh it doesn't
get you i hide the understatement it
takes you to the divine level of life
it's called the guard monocle
it's called cup in dc
that's actually called an old cup i mean
that's the toe right there wally no yeah
right there everybody give me all that
red chicken
be bigger than dre nah
i don't want i don't want that that [ __ ]
look like that man
i feel like
i'm gonna wake up like seven five with
that i came into this army listen i came
here 100 pounds overweight this [ __ ]
gave me the toad i don't lost 100 pounds
haven't been high in five years and then
what a whole bunch oh you've been high
we're not that high no no i've been i've
been i've been elevated
very elevated
all the time yeah very [ __ ]
i'm 55 years old i'm still i'm breaking
records
i live on pay-per-view when the last
time you had the tote
um last week
so you just be like yo so what you doing
i'm trying i want you to come over and
let me know the charm and come back you
just lick the top shaman comes over with
the with the listen you take the toasty
little bumps on the toad
you pierce the the pus out in the window
and what does it feel like when you
smoke it
do you lick it or smoke like what's
going on yeah i smoke i never licked
that nasty [ __ ]
his whole dynamics had told you it was
like yeah yeah that beautiful toad you
just get it over you just called it over
and i was like you'd be nasty
what does it feel like it feels like god
the whatever you know of god it feels
like whatever you think god could be
my boy neil brennan right he was talking
about was it ayahuasca
ayahuasca i did that that's not me but
it's good stuff for some people but it's
not me that's what i'm about right there
i want to see while later
you got to be ready to do this stuff
though like it's not like you know what
i'm saying like there has to be
something that really i gotta you gotta
have a purpose and when you're not i
guess
it's my favorite video game and i
haven't beat it yet
yeah i could do the i can battle the
toad
i thought i beat battletoads oh
it's crazy to try to explain you know
what i'm saying i think they did that on
like family guy or something like that
no they're fighting i don't know about
this no somebody did a lick the toad
episode of something it was a cartoon
that's all i remember oh no no they can
tell [ __ ]
yeah you know you know no exactly
hey
hey give me like two of them toads on my
next rider
i'm gonna come up with the toes i'm
gonna give me an iced out toad
then my hype man gonna be a shaman
and the whole show we just gonna be like
five smokes
nah we're just gonna nod
fives man is everybody vibing and we
just gonna pass around the toad to that
[ __ ] look like like a ninja turtle it's
got nothing left no
none of that colors left okay cool
can you help me get one of them toads
um
yeah
excuse me spanking them
but i smoke in the morning i mean really
really tough stuff
you gotta go to mexico
20 minutes
how did you turn it from saliva to but
it goes on it goes to the on the mirror
and it gets hard and then when you get
it hard and you stand it up like sand
and you smoke it put it in the pipe and
smoke it
and your life will change your heart
all that [ __ ] i've been through
how do i come here get this money shot
the [ __ ] i'm doing and then i just get a
hundred thousand dollars and [ __ ]
i say hey
right
the key is
do you feel like you're not worthy of
all this praise and stuff no yes i know
that um
yes this prayers is just i mean it's
nobody god made me interesting no
problem bro you gifted that's what it is
like not even though like [ __ ] like
also you just you was gifted as a child
you met the right people you you changed
your life you could have just been
somebody yeah but i don't take myself
that seriously
i'm not taking you serious i'm telling
you like what happened i'm not like
sugarcoating it hey man you you [ __ ]
prayed on the lucky star no no [ __ ] you
did that [ __ ] like
the [ __ ] he had a nintendo gang glass
joe [ __ ] listen right here glass joe
[ __ ] you never dig right can you
imagine hearing that all day
yeah yeah no i get like that too you
know that all day
you're the man you're the man
i mean yeah no i i feel him on that i
was with jack harlow right yeah we came
to the studio jack was like uh
he was like man you know
my reflexes i wasn't even trying to be i
was like yeah yeah right whatever i
couldn't even embrace the the love he
was giving me because i'm so jaded by
certain things in my industry so i know
what you're saying it's like gotta
humble you yeah no for sure for sure
even your praises you'll be like yeah i
i i i will you i don't [ __ ] around
almost none you're almost numb to the
time that i know yeah yeah all the glory
goes to him all the glory can you talk
about one of the humble humble
experiences mike
yes being nobody
yeah
can you imagine that like feeling
everybody and not being what was that
though huh what was that in my mind oh
yeah that's the yeah you know what i
mean that's the man in your mind
everything that goes on out here is
right in here if you feel like you
sometimes you feel like you're nobody or
this is before well i know i'm nobody
but i guess um
i know like that we have the expiration
date i'll be dead and it's just i'm gone
i just i just i i i wouldn't be able to
confidently ride home without like i got
to refute that bruh no you don't you're
not you're not no like what do you mean
nobody bro talk to me you mike tyson bro
yeah no but i think what i'm around mike
a lot bro he he literally like i can see
where he's coming from you know what i
mean like he because he's a nikon dude
he gets it a lot more than any of us you
know what i'm saying yeah like it's
always people that's why every time i'm
with mike i'm always like talking about
fighting you know what i mean i don't
know your thoughts on holyfield versus
v2 or you know you are
evolving to what way more than that you
and you're a hood [ __ ] you're a street
[ __ ] that knows how to talk to a [ __ ]
to like about nietzsche like knows how
to talk philosophy with [ __ ] like
you're going to be you're going to be
one of the big people that yeah
you know bridge the gap you can bridge
the gap i can do that too but also i
could suffer about when i hurt somebody
before if i beat somebody out of this
mind and have to just didn't treat
somebody with respect right so i got
that haunting me too that that oversees
all that greatness [ __ ] right my my
guiltless and my my everybody got shame
bro everybody got some things everybody
no matter what no matter what your field
is everybody got some things like their
decisions they didn't you know they wish
they didn't make you know what i'm
saying i don't know yours and then this
that's that's probably something for
some another time but i'm just saying
everybody nobody perfect bro nobody's
perfect but sometimes i just think that
you live with a lot of like a guilt like
a lot of guilt and it's unnecessary
and you have to be able to accept the
flowers
you have to because bro we're losing
we're losing legends we ain't losing you
no time soon i respect my inventory more
than anything so when i go back in my
inventory how was i today that that's
treat everybody with respect and advice
and if i pass that i'm i'm good today
yeah my start thinking about [ __ ] i call
that [ __ ] a [ __ ] so i said [ __ ] that
[ __ ] not even saying it but in my mind
thinking it and i didn't pass today bro
i've done so much [ __ ] too bro i call
complex magazine bro
i
they didn't put my one of my albums in
like 2012 in the top like
20 or top 50. and my out this [ __ ] went
like [ __ ] the numbers were great and the
reception was great my name put it i
called them i called the building
threatened everybody there really was
going
coming up there on that time until
[ __ ] like was like yo bro what are you
doing this is a magazine you know what
i'm saying
like bro like sometimes like sometimes
we can really just
forget all we did and and you say you
called this [ __ ] there call that [ __ ]
that call that [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] that
[ __ ] you evolve [ __ ] you you would
never level of a person right now but
you gotta do that inventory you can't
say [ __ ] that without doing the
invitation i didn't even remember i
didn't even remember i don't even
remember what we did [ __ ] we might have
been drunk whatever huh listen your
conscience don't lie to you you know
what you did even when you didn't do it
you know something was not right touched
yeah yeah you're right mike it's like i
learned i learned so much from you mike
and it all goes back to the basics of
thought the basics of inner peace the
basic of love you know what i'm saying
like it's so much it's so much it's so
simple if you really deep down look at
it but we all have sometimes i'm a self
how can i not be selfish [ __ ] i
always hear that but as long as don't
you accept it mike don't you don't you
recognize and accept when you are
selfish you're not selfish all the time
listen um i don't try to accept that i
tried to evacuate it no get it away from
me
you know i mean look buying the car
buying the house for me don't do it no
more it doesn't move me no more yeah you
know everybody's been doing it buying
something
now you're doing doing it
you know
now your motors are different now mike
yeah
when he's talking about evolve when did
you feel like the faces that you've
evolved in your career
or
or in your thought process
the toe the toe did everything that did
the toes they about to have toes on
stockx now toe was just telling me
conquer the world crush the world like
things
like six times i don't know that [ __ ]
was telling me this [ __ ] and listen
it's telling me this [ __ ] i got this
[ __ ] show
i got this [ __ ] big marijuana company
and listen right that's the toad
i'm not smart enough to navigate this
[ __ ] [ __ ] you talking about nietzsche
you're known as a tough person no i
don't know who i am
let's run it back dude
there is a ring here but we're going to
cut it back close close it out for us
bro what message you got why the [ __ ] is
mike tyson punch out so hard
hey brother i never played it a day in
my life never no no i think i've seen
something on youtube you playing that
joke no i was just doing it for the tell
of that never mind my life playing that
is your show i'm your co-host triple c
aka henry oh that's like oh that's a
hurry up that's it i might like i told
you smoking put this put the statue
outside my brother
put the statue outside the hospital and
the special ed programs for me and mike
and whoever was like us growing up
we out
[Music]
you